ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
se han dado cuenta que estamos tan
inmersos en el exterior que hemos dejado
de escuchar a nuestra voz interior
a ese niño que le gusta reír que no se
complica la vida con problemas él sabe
que la imaginación es más poderosa que
perder el tiempo pensando en que llegar
a demostrar del trabajo hoy un día
cansado no encontramos a uno sentido me
hice esta pregunta que estoy haciendo
con mi vida y con mi tiempo pude
descubrir dentro de mí lo que realmente
me apasiona lo que me hace ser yo tras
observar detenidamente noté que surgía
en las respuestas quise darle un sentido
a mi vida escribiendo bajo la
responsabilidad social y humana así fue
como surgió el primer cuento totalmente
escrito y desarrollado bajo la
observación
siendo adulto entendí que tras tener una
infancia normal había un vacío en mí que
no lo llenaban el juego de la familia
fue por medio de mi trabajo que se hizo
una invitación para acudir a la primera
casa hogar que visité
al dar mis primeros pasos dentro de ella
dos acontecimientos me mostraron una
realidad el rostro de la directora quien
al vernos llegar no pudo contener el
llanto y la segunda unos pequeños brazos
y una voz que me dijo tú eres mi papá
en ese momento una parte de mí se
conectó instantáneamente cada mirada
cada sonrisa fue un despertar de
emociones que comparó con la sensación
que experimenta un alpinista cada vez
que conquista la cima del everest y
desde esa altura se detiene unos
instantes para percibir cada detalle del
paisaje
no existe un método mágico para escribir
una buena historia
yo imagino un personaje que ya ha
resuelto un problema o ha conquistado un
sueño
posteriormente piensa en la conclusión
en el desarrollo y por último en el
título que lo haga parecer interesante
como cada escena para poder terminar el
cuento
cuando un niño lee se convierte en el
protagonista de su propia historia ya lo
dijo antoine de saint en su libro
titulado el principito he aquí mi
secreto que no puede ser más simple sólo
con el corazón se puede ver bien lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos fue así
que un día escribí george va casi
derrotado postrado sobre sus rodillas
con sus manos sobre el piso ardiente
pensaba en su familia a punto de perder
la esperanza recordó las palabras que el
consejo de sabios le había hecho en el
planeta callum una espada te será
otorgada a su debido tiempo y con ella
podrás enfrentar cualquier obstáculo
en ese momento un rayo que yo frente a
él
proporcionándole poderes inimaginables
una espada se transformó poco a poco
gracias a las oraciones de todas las
personas que habían pensado en él
joshua es real es un niño de 9 años que
ha vencido al cáncer
es difícil creer
que en este mundo un niño sufre sin
embargo hoy tengo noticias alentadoras
el mundo ideal es real se puede sentir
se puede tocar se puede percibir e
incluso saborear quieres saber cómo es
sólo debes preguntarle a un experto
billete y escucha lo que tiene que decir
que un niño pero debes hacer la pregunta
correcta como imaginas tú el mundo ideal
y él responderá en un mundo ideal
existen millones de colores nuevos hay
unicornios volando sobre el cielo nunca
terminamos de leer un cuento todos
compartimos lo que tenemos no existen
ladrones ni drogas todos los días
salimos a jugar con nuestra bicicleta
pero sobre todo en mi mundo ideal
no existe la guerra
cada vez que me conecto a mi mundo ideal
las palabras
tienen alas los grillos hablan todo se
conecta y adquiere sentido por eso
te invito a que escuches al dueño
interior aunque sigue llamando aún está
ahí y dice ven a jugar quiero verte
sonreír extrañas a rodillas sucias
llevan al parque otra vez
tira un gol
todos deberíamos escribir para acompañar
a un niño sus emociones
pues el alma necesite desahogarse por
eso vale la pena compartir esta idea
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]